hello and welcome to learning about it
with me Lulu I'm a chess instructor here
at the st. Louis chess club and
scholastic Center today we're going to
be learning about pins absolute pins and
relative pins all right so the game
begins with D for popular first move for
white which is meant by Knight f6
controlling the e4 square preventing
white from putting his pawn there white
plays c-4 preparing to get his Knight to
c3 next move and black meets us with C
six opening up that diagonal for his
Bishop preparing to pin and now the pin
for black is found here where he plays
Bishop to b4 pinning the knight to the
King an absolute pin because white
cannot move the knight without making
sure that the bishop won't be putting
his king in the check now white also has
an opportunity to make a pin by playing
his dark square Bishop to g5 pinning the
knight to the Queen a relative pin
because black could move the knight if
he wanted to and it's easier to break
than absolute pin so now to recap we've
learned about absolute pins and relative
pins the difference being that an
absolute pin means that a piece is
pinned to the King and can't move
however a relative pin means that a
piece is pinned to any piece besides the
King and the piece could move away and
that's it so thanks for learning about
it with me Lulu